ن وكن فق لنذكر ايضا الياس بان عده بلدات
ومدن في غلاف غزه قد اخليت اما بشكل كلي
او شبه كلي من المستوطنين بالنظر لوصول
الصواريخ الى هذه المناطق وكان هناك جدل
فيما يتعلق بقدره هؤلاء على العوده الى
هذه المناطق تجدد هذه الدفعات الصاروخيه
وبهذه الكثافه الي مذا يفرض تحديا ايضا في
هذا
الاطار وهذا هو السؤال الكبير حقيقه مياده
وهو سؤال في مكانه وهذا ما يعني يتحدث عنه
الكثير من الاسرائيليين في هذه الساعه بعد
هذه الضربه الصاروخيه الهائله على منطقه
الغلاف يعني الاسرائيليون هنا في هذه
البلدات اي ربما يسالون الحكومه
الاسرائيليه كيف تريدون لنا ان نعود الى
بلداتنا والى مدننا في منطقه الغلاف وهي
ما زالت تتعرض الى كل هذا الوابل الكبير
من صواريخ بمعنى هنالك لوم كبير وعدم ثقه
كبيره بالنسبه للاسرائيليين في هذه
البلدات فيما انجزه الجيش الاسرائيلي على
الصعيد العسكري في داخل قطاع غزه وعن فشل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الواضح في تحديد في
تحقيق اهداف هذه ال الحرب يعني واضح تماما
بان الاهداف اي لم تكن كثيره كانت ثلاثه
اهداف اي تتحدث عن القضاء على حركه حماس
وقدرتها العسكريه والسطو وتتحدث عن
استعاده ال الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين
في داخل قطاع غزه وان لا يشكل القطاع
منطلقا لاي اعمال ضد اسرائيل او اي خطر
امني على اسرائيل ثلاثه اهداف واضحه لم
يتحقق منها شيء يعني حتى الوزراء في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وحتى اعضاء الائتلاف
الحاكم في اسرائيل يقرون ويقولون بان
اسرائيل بعد يومين وبعد المئه لم تحقق اي
شيء على صعيد تحقيق هذه الاهداف ونحن نرى
ايضا في هذا الاطار مياده الخلافات التي
بدات تطفو على السطح بشكل واضح في داخل
مجلس الحرب حول المسار الذي يجب ان تسلكه
هذه الحكومه في عمر هذه الحرب واي توجه
نحن نرى ان هنالك توجهين في داخل مجلس
الحرب هو استمرار التصعيد العسكري
والعمليات العسكريه وواضح بان المستفيد من
هذه الرؤيا وطبعا وزير الدفاع اسرائيلي
افغان يتمسك بهذه الفكره ويدعمه بذلك رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو لكن بنيامين
نتنياهو هو ربما المستفيد الوحيد من اطاله
عمر هذه الحرب وتكثيف العمليات العسكريه و
وتعزيزها ربما وتصعيدها في قادم الايام
وفي قادم الاسابيع لانه يعلم تماما انه
بعد انتهاء الحرب فان شريكه بين جان سوف
ينسحب من حكومه الوحده الوطنيه بشكل فوري
لذلك هو باطاله عمر هذه الحرب هو يخاطب
الجنم جناح المتطرف في حكومته بتسل ايس
مترش وتمار بنفير الذين حذرا من ان اي وقف
للعمليات العسكريه سيؤدي بهما الى
الاستقاله من الحكومه الاسرائيليه لذلك
نتنياهو لا يريد ان يفقد القاعده الشعبيه
واليمنيه المتطرفه التي تستند عليها
الحكومه لانه يعلم انه بعد الحرب سيفقد
شريكه بيني جانز ومن ناحيه اخرى الاصوات
التي تتمثل بموقف الوزير جادي ايزنكوت
الذي يقول بان اسرائيل لم تنجز شيئا على
الصعيد العسكري وربما عليها ان تجنح نحو
المفاوضات مع حركه حماس وتحقيق صفقه
لتبادل الاسرى في هذا السياق